alright let's talk about Megan Markel
now her fashion has been emulated
worldwide but in tonight's ET Beauty one
woman has taken her love of the Duchess
next level I wanted a strong jawline
like Megan I wanted a more refined nose
like Megan I wanted my figure to be a
little bit slimmer like Megan just
really nice and tight
this was Houston lawyer Shoji Greer
before she had a total Megan market
makeover I had some fat crops put into
my cheeks liposuction to the abdomen
liposuction to the inner and outer
thighs and then I had fat grafts into
the buttocks to give me a little nice
lift I had filler in the jaw line to
give me a stronger straw I had filler in
my lips and under my eyes all those
procedures cost around $30,000 cameras
from ABC's Nightline followed her into
the operating room last November
really excited to see these results
what's this buddy goes out once all the
bruising went away and they hit the
swelling went down I looked in the
mirror and I just felt a happy again
this single mom of three says after her
surgery her youngest daughter actually
confused her with the Duchess I do have
a large cutout of Megan and she sees
that she's she thinks it's a picture of
me she's like money and she points to it
and she's like mommy mommy mommy um you
know I'm like no that's not mommy
and this 36 year old says she's open to
looking for love on a reality show I did
apply for married at first sight I
actually had a friend who's like I'm
gonna put your name in the Hat for
bachelor would I do it I don't I don't
know she's thrilled with her plastic
surgery results but has there been a
downside of going under the knife to
resemble a royal the only backlash that
I've received so far is some very nasty
messages telling me that I look nothing
like her I should be asking the doctor
for refunds there have been some really
mean comments but I try not to read them
[Music]